Let us start from where we left off when we finished [UNKNOWN] analysis.
This was the current state, this was the goal state. As we saw from
[UNKNOWN] analysis, achieving this goal state is not a very easy problem.
However, we can think of this goal state as being composed of several sub goals,
so D on top of table. C on top of D. B on top of C. A on top of B.
Four sub goals here. Now, we can try to address this problem by looking at
one sub goal at a time. Let us suppose that we have picked this sub goal,
C on top of D. Give that sub goal, we can now start from this current state and
try to achieve this sub goal. Now of course, one might ask the question, why did
we pick the goal C over D, and not the goal, B over C, or the goal A over B?
Well one reason is that, the difference between this state and that state had to
do with C over D. But in general, problem reduction by itself does not tell us,
what sub-goal to attack first. That is a problem, we'll address later when we
come to planning. Well now the major point is, that we can decompose the goal
into several subgoals, and attack one subgoal at a time. Now that we have C over
D as a subgoal, we really don't carry about whether A is on B or B is on C. What
we are focused on is the other two states, C on table, D on table, because those
are the blocks that occur in the goal state. So let us now see how [INAUDIBLE]
have been solved this sub problem [INAUDIBLE] goal C on D and D on Table.